hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
kochwelt heute gibt es wieder was
leckeres herzhaftes und zwar habe ich
heute leckere gewollte kleine teilchen
die idee stammt von einem video was ich
schon mal gemacht hatte und zwar habe
ich hier einen leckeren teig aus mehl
butter und frischkäse und da kommt sonst
nix rein und den teig habe ich euch
schon mal gezeigt in diesem video und
deswegen zeige ich euch denn heute nicht
mehr da ist schon richtig schön gekühlt
und ich hatte das in diesem anderen
video mit einer leckeren süßen füllung
gemacht und heute kommt eine leckere
herzhafte füllung und ich zeige euch
jetzt einfach mal meine zutaten sind
jetzt aber wieder nur beispiele und
vorschläge und ihr könnt natürlich die
creme und die zutaten einfach wieder
austauschen
ich nehme jetzt etwas frischkäse ich
habe jetzt hier wieder die doppel rahmen
stufe ich meine wer will auch schon fett
sparen hier etwas parmesan käse darauf
werde ich gleich den teig ausrollen
ich nehme etwas paprika mag für die
schärfe das habe ich jetzt von bagdad
das ist richtig schön scharf hier etwas
zu tun
man kann es natürlich auch vegetarisch
machen aber wir sind irgendwie kratz und
süchtig das ist auch eine türkische klub
nach wurst hier ein paar getrocknete
tomaten die habe ich bei aldi war schon
in öl eingelegt
ich versuche noch etwas olivenpaste ich
glaube die pasta richtig gut dazu und
ich nehme etwas pfeffer und kräutern
oregano und minze und aus diesen zutaten
werde ich jetzt eine leckere creme
herstellen und mach das jetzt alles in
einem mixer falls ihr keine mixa habt
müsste einfach alle zutaten richtig fein
schneiden
ich bereite jetzt die creme zu und es
werde jetzt mit 70 improvisierte creme
und war nämlich jetzt zu tun und es
sicher richtig schön weich deswegen geht
es damit auch gut und ihr dürft ihr beim
kochen einfach improvisieren
laut meyer und es gebe jetzt da rein und
versucht es aber einfach gleich zu
vermissen
und dann wird es noch richtig leckere
creme weiß jetzt schon
ich glaub ich noch ein bisschen
damit sich das noch schön und da kommen
jetzt die getrockneten und in öl
eingelegte tomaten mit dazu die sollen
ja auch klein werden
und ich habe hier hinten noch ein paar
basilikumblätter abgezockt
hier gebe ich auch mit rein und bittet
da kommt jetzt noch frischkäse dazu da
nehme ich jetzt mal die ganze packung
also 200 gramm und ich hab's paprika mal
vergessen da geb ich auch noch ungefähr
1 teelöffel dazu
das war schon so sollte die creme dann
aussehen und sie riecht schon mal fertig
und jetzt nehme ich mal ein paar mal
sahen käse und reibt den feind und das
mache ich jetzt direkt auf meine silikon
arbeits mathe bin da werde ich auch
gleich den teig ausrollen und jetzt
können wir die teilchen auch schon auf
rollen fabrizierten käsige reden und
gebe es hier noch etwa einen esslöffel
von jedem kräuter gräser mit dazu also
oregano und minze
das war möchte ich jetzt hier einfach
ein bisschen dass ich das schön verteilt
und jetzt lege ich mal ein teil davon
weg und nehme meinen teig das ist kalt
und dann teile ich den teig in vier
portionen
und braucht jetzt erst mal nur einen
teil und den rolle ich jetzt auf diesen
parmesankäse mit den kräutern aus
richtig schön rund auf etwa 26 cm
durchmesser
jetzt nehme ich mir diesen portionierer
und teilt den teig in 16 stücke das geht
aber auch ohne portion ihre einfach kurz
vor vor stampfen und dann könnte das
einfach durchschneiden
normalerweise darf man nicht mit zu
einem rädchen auf silikon motto
schneiden uns einfach ganz vorsichtig
und jetzt kommt auch unsere leckere
füllung zum einsatz
damit bestreitet jetzt den teig
und dann können die teilchen einfach
aufgerollt werden
und ist sie jetzt schon richtig leckeren
wenn man die teigstücke etwas größer
macht also zum beispiel nur acht statt
dann kann man da zum beispiel auch so
kleine mini würstchen reihen rollen oder
schinken oder etwas anderes was euch
gefällt vielleicht auch auf gemüse man
kann sie auch vegetarisch machen
ich versuch's doch immer wieder aber
irgendwie kommt zu tube irgendwie jedes
mal ins spiel
ich habe jetzt mal nur die hälfte ist
gewollt
die andere hälfte habe ich mir auf und
macht morgen denn bei uns gibt sie rollt
jetzt zur vorspeise und wir haben noch
eine gute nachspeise und noch ein
hauptgericht und das reicht auf jeden
fall für uns und die werden jetzt im
ofen bei 180 grad für etwa 20 minuten
gebacken
die backzeit richtet sich nach eurem
ofen sie sollen einfach schön goldbraun
werden
und wenn sie fertig sind zeige ich euch
gleich hier duftet jetzt schon richtig
lecker die förmchen sind jetzt fertig
und wir werden sie auch gleich probieren
und da zusätzlich selber ersten auch
einen schönen zeller zählt auch noch
etwas heißt also ich kann jetzt nicht
direkt probieren und demokratisch
inzwischen auch schon da und hat gesagt
ich nach pizza pizza
das sind leckere hörnchen soll ruhig
aber heiß und kann strauss schmecken
muss sich uli die olivenpaste habe man
nicht benutzt eigentlich wollten wir
auch mit drauf streichen huber lampen
vergessen
nein das ist eine leckere suppe kreml
seine viel zu tun frischkäse job tomaten
los ist richtig lecker und und sich
während dem dreh oder besser gesagt der
car immerhin oder kamera eingefallen
karima was kann man auch nehmen oder
lachs kamera einrollen also da gibt es
eigentlich alles mögliche um jedem
schmeckt irgendwas ihr könnt ihr einfach
mal den teig machen und in den
kühlschrank schauen was drin steht und
irgendwas dann davon rausnehmen und wenn
ihr eigene kreationen habt könnt ihr sie
mir unten in die kommentare
reinschreiben oder einfach direkt als
foto bei instagram oder facebook posten
ich werde mein rezept von meiner
kreierten creme einfach auf den block
stellen bei salis - blog.de und da gibt
es die genauen mengenangaben und ich
freue mich schon aufs nächste mal wieder
bis bald